okay so let's
do a little overview of where we can
find such data
and what does this data
look like or what can it be used for
so again not not a long time because we
will spend a little bit more time on
some of the practical things so you can
try and get get started but we'll do a
brief overview so one of the things that
you will find very useful i think and
intuitive is this american gut micro uh
american gut project
the american guy project is a citizen
science project dedicated to metagenomic
sequencing of world citizens that are
contributing their microbiome samples to
the study of healthy or almost healthy
microbiome variability so the idea is
can we ask people to collect their
microbiome samples
skin and gut samples send them sequence
them and then we are starting to collect
this
natural variability and one of the
examples that you will find in the
american gut microbiome project which we
will actually try and do in this program
is
look at an individual single sample
right so let's say i contribute my
sample
how can i look at my sample for example
you can see right here my sample is this
first bar
compared to the average
similar diet so people that are on a
similar diet like myself
same gender similar bmi age
and some individual michael poland in
this case so some individual that we can
compare and as you can see the
comparison consists of different colors
here
that are annotated right here
and for uh you know kind of
understanding my individual sample now
we can start looking at the most
abundant microbes at different levels of
taxonomy
so these different levels of taxonomy
now can give us some reference that we
can try and see
what is known about these individual
microorganisms or taxa of microorganisms
down below you'll see how different
sides
so
hmp here stands for human microbiome
project so that's where we get the
reference kind of how does this compare
to the population
uh so how can we compare to some of
these other sources of information
from different body sites
different ages and populations and the
american gut population so
this is a project that i think is
fascinating
provides us an insight into what could
be done just kind of to understand
what's going on but also together with
this information you can find metadata
so
that was sequencing data
what are the microorganisms that are
present this is an example of metadata
so this is metadata from the human
microbiome project the human microbiome
project contains a lot of different
variables that are being collected from
individuals
and in this one example we are using a
comparison between people that exercise
rarely and exercised regularly
so here you can see
we can control for certain conditions
for example they don't have
the liver disease
they are considered to be a healthy
subset of people
they rarely or maybe regularly
supplement with vitamin d but the
biggest difference here is that the
exercise is
never versus daily right so
one of the questions that you could ask
from such data is if we control for as
much as we know for the different
factors could we find
some individuals that are different in
one particular way and then based on
that difference you know see whether
there is or is not a difference in their
microbiome so just an exploratory simple
question and we'll take a look today at
some of the ways that you can start
thinking about these questions
uh using this kind of data
another example that we will look at is
how the skin microbiome varies
uh between acne
and what's called perioral dermatitis
so a very common condition that a lot of
people have either experienced
or may might continue to experience
you know
the perioral dermatitis is more of a a
rash and acne is a more acute condition
and then of course we also have areas of
healthy skin so one of the questions
could be
you know how do these microbes
essentially interact with the skin
itself
in inflammatory acne right so how do
they cause inflammation
and so here in this discussion we can
also download the data and we'll look uh
today at where this data could be found
and try to understand what are some of
the differences so in this case
the difference is represented in this
image right here which is a
non-metric dimensionality scaling
plot that allows us to see different
samples positioned in this
two-dimensional space
and maybe show us specific grouping
based on this annotation kind of giving
us a sense overall whether these samples
are different
or not and and here we have three
different samples
adult acne none which is healthy control
and perioral dermatitis
another more complicated study in terms
of how it was performed and exactly what
was done to develop the data to kind of
prepare the data is a study
that was published
in 2015
that spoke about obese gut microbiota
induced neurobehavioral changes in the
absence of obesity right so in this case
the researchers were trying to separate
the obesity
itself for example resulting in
some genetic predisposition or maybe in
some kind of a diet from the impact of
the actual microbiome or the you know
the composition of microbiota so could
we actually take
the microbiota of mice that were fed a
high-fat diet
use that microbiota to
implant a specific composition into a
healthy mouse
and then see whether that led to some
neurobehavioral changes
and
if you read this publication you will
find that yes they found an association
with anxiety and these kinds of patterns
of behavior but what we can try and do
is we can try and take this data and try
to understand differences between
several different types of data that are
available with this publication now of
course these kinds of publications
illustrate some of the approaches they
can become
more and more complex in nature
and you will find that there is a great
interest in trying to understand the
functionality the functional
applications and even develop treatment
for example here you can see
a treatment for alzheimer's disease that
targets the microbiome
so different types of applications of
microbiome obviously going beyond some
of the basic research questions and
trying to incorporate the micro the
microbial signatures into into practical
applications including clinical
applications like treatment
or even understanding of um the impact
on other types of treatments like for
example
immunotherapy
today living in the pandemic
of course we all might have questions
about well what is the relationship
between the microbiome and
19
and here's an example of a study
where
the
microbial diversity is being studied
for
long covert and for susceptibility so
here you will find high-risk groups
coming to covet 19
and
as a result of the pandemic providing us
with such
tremendous quantity of data
some researchers decided to collect that
data as well
and uh found some differences between
the length to recovery
and the speed of recovery as well
the microbiome is also
used not only in medicine but also
biotechnology and agriculture for
example microbial fertilizers mfs
constitute an emerging class of organic
fertilizers and consist of dried
microbial biomass for instance produced
on effluents from the food and beverage
industry they have been shown to provide
unique benefits especially in harsh
conditions at the same time with minimal
environmental impacts metagenomic
studies on agricultural applications of
microbiome are showing promise and many
have already started using this approach
to improve yield and resilience of crops
and so the types of applications of
metagenomic sequencing and sequence
analysis really
continue and
go on and on and what we'll see is we
will see
how
these types of metagenomic studies
focused on the microbiome as a whole
are very different from the way
microorganisms can be studied in
isolation but just to compare and
contrast here are some examples of
microorganism studies in isolation not
as a community where you can see
drug resistance viral adaptation or
association with a particular
phenotype that could be studied once you
have the full genome of the
microorganism
okay so now let's talk a little bit
about some of the practical things that
we can do
to analyze such data and again this is
not going to be a very detailed overview
but it should provide you with a high
level understanding of some of the
practical activities that you should be
able to do
after completing this training and uh
you know how you can continue thinking
about some of the research questions
that we covered up until now and
try them on different types of data sets
so the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to try
and
learn this data to pipeline just by
understanding the sequence of steps how
do we go from raw data to process data
and then what are some of the outputs
what are some of the visualizations that
we can get at the end so to do that
let's go to the server which is
server.tbio.info
this is a platform
that has a lot of the methods
implemented in a user-friendly
environment
and
in addition to that you will get some
demo examples where you don't even need
to run any analysis you just need to
understand and visualize some of the
data
so please log into this
platform
if you don't have a login for example
you just joined today you haven't really
registered yet
you won't be able to do this together
with us now but if you have created an
account on learn within 24 hours you
should be receiving your account details
so just to get a sense of how many of
you already have an account could